ليس فقط في العراق في
أي مكان
بشكل جيد ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك ، إنه لأمر رائع أن
أكون مع الرئيس بارزاني من
كوردستان ولدينا جدول زمني رائد لفترة
طويلة أردنا أن نلتقي به ، لقد
عملنا معًا جيدًا
كما تعلم أننا غادرنا سوريا من
وجهة نظر الحدود
، وقد نجح هذا الأمر بشكل رائع مع تركيا ،
فقد نجح في العمل بشكل أفضل بكثير مما
اعتقد أي شخص أنه من الممكن أن يكون لديهم
ما يسمى بالمنطقة الآمنة ، وأنا أقدر
كل ما قمت
به للحفاظ على سلامته قدر الإمكان ، ولكن الأمر
مهم جدًا مثلك  أعلم
أن لدينا النفط واه تركنا
جنودًا للنفط لأننا نأخذ النفط
ونعمل على ذلك وقد قمنا
بتأمينه بشكل جيد جدًا ،
ولدينا أيضًا الآلاف من أسرى داعش ، وقد
أخذنا أكثر من 100 من
الخلافة وهو
منطقة ممتعة للغاية ولكن لدينا
علاقة هائلة
ومن الرائع أن أكون معك شكرًا
جزيلاً شكرًا جزيلاً لك
شكرًا جزيلاً لك ، شكرًا لك ، من دواعي
سروري أن أغتنم هذه الفرصة
لأشكرك السيد الرئيس على الاستلام  أنت
تعلم أنني في دافوس
كما قلت ، تعلم أننا كنا ننتظر
وقتًا طويلاً
جدًا لهذه اللحظة ، شكرًا لك على
قيادتك ،
شكرًا لك على دعمك ، لذلك
هزمنا داعش معًا بشكل صحيح
وأم بالنيابة عن الناس  أعني في
كوردستان أود أن
أعبر عن شكرنا وأن أوصلك إلى
قيادتك ودعمك